and the grinder goes to future nostalgia  duality  future nostalgia means the absolute  world to me let's do this thing  yes yes  i've been doing my laps hot performance  and you walk away with the grammy what  did this night mean to you  just the absolute world you know to be  alongside so many of my peers so many  artists that inspire me  to also see so many incredible women  picking up awards making history  to be a part of that was just  mind-blowing and to get an award  for my album future nostalgia is all i  could ever hope for  it really really means a lot to me so  i'm just so happy and  i like that people like the performance  i was really happy about that and that's  that's  [Music]  already